Here are some things that a data scientist may do
in his or her daily work. They might wrangle data. That
is, collect data from the real world, process it, and
create a data set that can be analyzed. Once they have
a data set, they may analyze trends in the existing
data or try to make data driven predictions about the future
using the data at hand. Based on this models or predictions,
they cannot only build data driven products but also communicate their
findings to those other data scientists and the general
public. File visualizations, reports or blog posts. But hey,
this is my point of view. Why don't we
talk to some other data scientists and hear their thoughts.